Thomas Alva Edison. Boys!
I trust you brought your checkbooks.
I'm so full of ideas it will take me 12 lifetimes to execute them
I'm working on something now. Something so new that the world will never be the same
I'm George Westinghouse.
Edisons' new electric system is
Significantly cheaper than gas does that keep you up at night? There's always more to see
We are gonna be big
Edison says he's months away from lighting up the world
Stoves, washing machines, electric carriages. I could do the same thing with electricity that I do with gas
Westinghouse Electric Company.
Edison Electric it has to be
Are you rich?
At the moment
Vultures in every venture, gotta keep them away. This is what he thinks of you.
Don't let him agitate you.
This is how he is. Sue him. Westinghouse Electric shall endure
He's a parasite. His current kills people.
Only because you said it would
Mr. Edison if you say something about me or my company again, I would ask that you tell the truth
Automation. Transportation. Communication. The man that controls that current,
Controls that future.
Though he may be unfamiliar to you his studies have demonstrated an understanding of electrical matters unlike anyone I have ever known
Gentlemen and Lady
Nikola Tesla.
So what's your trade?
I fix problems for idiots